it's on the mound for the padres is
blake snell 28 year old making his 21st
start he's got a cut down on the walks
last time out through 105 pitches in
five innings he did get the w he's got a
2.81 era here at petco park they need to
win two out of three against these
diamondbacks stepping up to the plate
for the diamondbacks lead off hitter
nick ahmed one twos is swinging a miss
and a good way to start the day for
blake snell he strikes out nick ahmed
with the breaking ball perfect location
not much a hitter can do with that pitch
there one out for kutel marte
fly ball down the left field line
towards the corner fam is over towards
the line and tommy pham is able to make
the catch up against the wall makes the
grab for out number two
robs could tell martay
talk about great concentration the leap
he secures it and then up against the
wall one pitch and calhoun swings pops
it up left side of the infield
cronenworth coming in towards the mount
he was the only guy there now in front
of the mound and jake makes the catch
then the inning was dicey was just in a
weird spot and uh cronenworth able to
make the play a one two three top of the
first four blake snell mad bomb on the
mound looking to win his third straight
start coming off back to back seven
inning outings gave up four hits and two
runs against the rangers gave up six
hits and one run against the giants he
has been on quite the role lately he's
the guy he won on the mound today
andre's third in the national league
west seven and a half games behind the
first place giants
fly ball headed to right center field
patel marte takes over and makes the
catch out there in right center
reaches out drops this one in left field
for a base hit
david smith throwing to second trying to
make it two and safe at second base a
double for adam frazier he was thinking
two out of the box
one out runner and second brings up
manny machado
shoots it to right center incoming is
calhoun and he'll make the catch for out
number two no advance for frazier who
returns to the bag it's second with now
two down lefty to lefty cronenworth
making his fourth consecutive start at
shortstop with tatis on the il gets a
breaking ball and lines it into center
field for a base hit fraser will score
easily and the padres have a one-nothing
lead in the first jake cronenworth with
his 52nd rbi
of the season oh he's in the ground zone
who doesn't love the chew out rbi
kronerworth to the pull side off of
bumgarner the lefty on lefty nola had a
big hit last night he pops this one up
while the infield fog round drew ellis
camps under it and he makes a catch in
foul territory nola's out the inning's
over but the padres get the lead for
snell it's marta the switch hitter
batting right-handed oh for one he hit a
ball deep down the left field line in
the first inning two here it is and
martay swings and misses at a pitch of
the dirt that is strike three and now
six strikeouts for snell
one out in the top of the fourth inning
one out for cole calhoun
swing and a miss
make it seven strikeouts for snell two
in a row he's got it going on today
stelzilla he's aggressive with the
fastball he's spinning it up there with
the curveball and the slider that's the
slider right there for the seventh
strikeout two outs and carson kelly at
first base
swing and a foul tip into the catcher's
mitt for strike three
ends up striking out the side
there is cronenworth who's knocked in
the game's only run a bloop single in
the center driven to right field
calhoun going back oh that's going in to
the kill zone
jake cutterworth connects on his 16th of
the year he's doing it all we're just
living in the crowd zone
jake cooks this ball gets out in a hurry
calhoun gives the courtesy turn but this
ball is a rocket two down here in the
fifth inning for jake hager to fly ball
out so far here in the fifth
and a liner into right center field the
first hit of the day
for the diamondbacks comes with two outs
in the fifth inning so there it is just
the first hit of the day off blake's now
but he gets into the fifth without
giving up a hit
two and two to bum garner and a swing
and a miss there's number nine for blake
snow diamondbacks get their first hit of
the day a two-out single by jake hager
one out ahmed at third base and brings
up cole calhoun
02 did he go yes he did adam hamari
rings him up third base umpire that's
ten strikeouts for blake schnell two
down two down ahmed at third base and
carson kelly
snail ready again three and two and on
the inside corner strike three called
back to back-to-back strikeouts to end
the sixth snell works around the lead
double by nick ahmed and he has tied his
season high 11 strikeouts in six shut
out it haven smith is coming up he
represents the potential tying run
2-2 is did he go yes he did david smith
strikes out making 12 k's for blake snow
how about that darvish with 12 last
night snell with 12 today i'll take a
dozen strikeouts please jake hager
struck out and singled he is one for two
stillzilla's got 13 strikeouts today
ties a career high he has done so in
seven shutout innings and as we have
reached the middle of the seventh the
padres will take a two-nothing lead to
the bottom half one and two
and peralta swings and misses strike
three back to back hayes
emilio pagan
base is empty two down marte coming up
and my goodness
what's that 23 outs
recorded by padre pitching 15 by
strikeout no balls and two strikes
here's the pitch from pagan and that is
lined right at fraser little hoppy makes
the catch and the side is retired a two
strikeout one two three eighth inning
for emilio pigan
2-1 frazier
lying towards cattell martell
it's a base hit and the third hit of the
day for adam frazier
bat to ball adam frazier is one of the
best at it down and in head down
continues to play well in this padre
uniform two down frazier at first for
machado
on the ground softly hit third baseman
ellis on the run it's late
man he's got himself an infield hit
as frazier takes second base well as a
hitter you look to your left you look to
your right where the infielders are
positioned and as this one is topped
man he can smell a base hit belanson
back at it again he's been brilliant in
these spots all season long
all calhoun sends one to the wall in
right field mauriznick plays the karum
and cole calhoun gets it started a
leadoff double in the ninth and the
diamondbacks will get the timing right
at the plate with no outs there you go
mark malanson going straight aerosmith
this inning living on the edge
on the ground to short chronoworth on
the backhand the throw is good two down
no advance for calhoun 2-2 pitch from
melanson hey struck him on the padres
win
two strikeouts in the ninth for the
padres that's 17 in the game for padres
pitching